let's say that changing the world
is like uprooting a tree like a big old
tall tree
imagine there were two founders
one founder
knew
that trees have roots
and the other founder had no idea
right
like
the trees with roots person
they have an advantage they have a very
large advantage the tree without roots
person they're gonna have a lot of very
horrible
uh how do i freeze this on the job
learning so yeah
it's not moving like we don't get it
like like we
we we're pushing it in it won't fall
over yeah we've done all the math like
if the tree ends right where the ground
begins like pushing like this it should
it should work
hey this is michael cybel with dalton
caldwell and welcome to rookie mistakes
we asked yc founders for their rookie
mistakes so we could share them with you
and help you avoid them
here's the next comment that was written
by oyc founder
we built a product because we thought
the world should be a certain way
not because we had a customer who
actually wanted to buy the thing we were
building
this is coming from a pure place and we
look at our heroes right we look at elon
musk
we look at steve jobs and we have this
model of people that forced the universe
to their will and and elon
electric cars of the future i am going
to impart electric cars i'm going to
make it happen and and again he kind of
did good for him right but
for most of us mere mortals
it's pretty hard to force people to want
the thing that you're selling or the
thing that you think is good for them
it's really hard
if someone doesn't want something to
like debate them
and convince them they do actually want
it when they don't actually want it most
people don't have organic experience
with sales and so they kind of
their vision is like oh i walked onto a
used car lot to look around and this
genius salesforce person convinced me to
buy this car and it's like
that's not even how
it works in real life you didn't just
randomly walk on the used car
nobody who doesn't
want to touch that you made a great
point do you know what you know what
kind of idea we always come like i would
come up with is guess what buying a car
sucks and dealing with car salesman
sucks buying a house sucks let's just
like build a website and we'll get rid
of car dealers so this is an example of
that it's like you kind of run into
something that's annoying
and you you're like yeah let's just get
rid of that and
again i'm with you let's get rid of that
you know i don't like buying a car
either but i think what happens when you
again haven't done the research yeah is
you were like oh actually there's a
reason car dealers exist and oh and
actually there's incentives
for these you know this is like like the
more you dig into that you you realize
that
you can't just wave a magic wand and
make car dealers go away
you can't just sprinkle software on the
property yeah or like realtors like
buying a house why is it so hard to buy
a house well you know
yeah
i don't even know how to summarize that
but like like a lot of founders want to
believe they can just like start a
company and revolutionize the home sales
process right so i feel where it's
coming from but in practice
the simplistic engineering efficiency
arguments don't always work when applied
to the real world
yeah i mean you know about this from
hiring right like haven't you seen this
with hiring i see this
all the time i see the hiring startup
applies to yc
and the thesis is always the same
i'm an engineer i'm a genius engineer
and i'm being assessed by a
non-technical recruiter
this is a crime like this is a crime
against humanity like it's it's um
dehumanizing that i have to go through
this experience
and if only the hiring manager was
empowered with software
the entire
recruiting team and all recruiters would
just go away disappear off the face of
the earth
through the hiring manager and software
and
what's weird is that like i kind of
believe the premise like i believe
an engineer is better at determining
whether another engineer is good or bad
however i also look at the way the world
is organized and i ask myself well if it
seems consistently organized that these
massive teams of recruiters exist at all
these companies there must be some
efficiency going on that i don't
understand right and the one core thing
that i've learned is that
even though engineers are better
at creating other engineers there are
two other facts one they don't tend to
enjoy doing it
and two it doesn't tend to be the
greatest way to extract value out of a
great engineer yeah it's not the best
use of their time like if you're
employing engineers you don't really
want them to spend all their time doing
this you want them to be doing their
jobs
and so
what's funny is that like hiring
companies inevitably run against this
like you aren't going to defeat hr
you aren't going to get rid of all the
recruiters
even though you don't believe they
should exist in the world they are going
to exist in the world either you're
going to accommodate them
or they will kill you like they tend to
actually have way more power than you
might think
in the end of the day
the hiring manager is like
you know this comes up a lot like the
the hiring manager is your like talk
friend but not your action friend like
it's the person you talk to is like oh
yeah i wish i never had to use these
recruiters like i wish i'd have to do
this i always get all these bad
candidates but they never do the thing
you want them to do like use your
product all the time
to push back on ourselves hey
what are dalton and michael saying
they're not saying you should try to
change things like shouldn't
aren't we you know shouldn't you be
trying harder to make the system better
let me let me let me answer that
first i don't know what you say michael
all we're saying
is you can make huge changes in human
behavior
if you really understand the subtle
pressure points
you've got to really understand the
motivations of all of the key parties
and cater to those motivations cater to
human institutions like like the people
that do really change the way the world
works
got a lot of small things right in the
earliest stages
like ride sharing like
the idea of getting to a stranger's car
and then driving to the airport was like
bizarre when it came out our younger our
younger viewers may not remember what it
was like but at the time it was like
yeah here's my idea a stranger comes to
your house and you get in the back seat
of the toyota right that's normal we
would have that was insane and so to
actually architect something like ride
sharing you had to really
understand all of the people involved
they actually started off with those
hired cars those like limo cars which
was normal yeah so there's all these
like little things that had to happen
for that idea to actually work and to
normalize ride sharing that if you
didn't understand all the core
constituents and you're just like hey
cars are inefficient we should have more
we should let people share rides
how many times has yc funded that idea
before uber and it didn't work this was
actually a really common bad startup
idea was ride sharing isn't that
hilarious yeah and so it's
i guess the point we're making here and
again i wanna hear what you think of
this michael
you just need to understand the little
things folks you need to understand the
small motivations of all people involved
in an ecosystem
and
and design the thing well
rather than just thinking you can burst
in this burst down to the scene with
something
and like everyone will magically use
your solution and boom you know hey
there's no more realtors we can just buy
and sell a house on a website like it's
more complicated than that man you have
to have a really someone will solve this
eventually
maybe someone watching this video but
you have to really
look at the intricate motivations of
every person involved and have an answer
for why they're incentivized to use your
thing
you know i'm gonna try to come up with
the bad analogy on the spot
let's say that changing the world
is like uprooting a tree like a big old
tall tree
imagine there were two founders
one founder
knew
that trees have roots
and the other founder had no idea
right
like
the trees with roots person
they have an advantage they have a very
large advantage the tree without roots
person they're gonna have a lot of very
horrible
uh how do i freeze this on the job
learning so yeah i mean it's not moving
like we don't get it like like we
we we're pushing it down it won't fall
over yeah we've done all the math like
if the tree ends right where the ground
begins like pushing like this it should
it should work
that's a great way to say it there's so
much under the surface
there's so much on the surface to
understand with a lot of these ideas and
if you don't understand it you're yeah
you're gonna learn like like
you'll get some much on the job training
that's a great way to say it yes
here was the next um comment that was
written in
yc founder wrote we did not do enough
research before deciding what to work on
we now realize the more research you do
in your space before you write a line of
code the better
it seems like people go to the effort of
starting a company
of trying to raise money for a company
of applying to yc with a company of
making it to yc interviews with a
company
and we can tell you haven't googled it
you haven't typed in like the idea that
you're working on into google or read
any articles about folks that have tried
it before and this is such
a self-own
um
it's free to do research on those that
came before you and failed cost you
nothing doesn't take very much time and
to spend years of your life or months of
your life or any amount of your life on
an idea that you've not done just basic
cursory research on
is really dumb
do you understand like
maybe you'll do it better or different
but to not even understand what came
before you is kind of a willful
ignorance
and i don't get that
right it's almost like do you think
michael do you think it's that they
don't want to know
or that they just don't think it applies
to them or oh this time it's different
like why would you obstinately refuse to
research related companies in the past
i would say one this is very commonly a
young founder um issue and one thing i
see about young founders is their like
internet knowledge doesn't go way back
so like i think the first mistake is
like well if i haven't heard of a
company trying to do this
that means the company has never tried
to do it um
i think the second thing that people do
is they ask their friends here this is a
situation where like googling is
probably a hundred times better than
asking your friends because like if
you're a young person whose internet
history is like four years old your
friends are probably in the similar
position
um and then i think the last thing is a
bit of a psychological thing i think
that's what you're getting to which is
if i'm so excited to do this why would i
want to learn something
that would like defeat it before it
started yeah you know like can i live in
the illusion in the dream for a little
longer and again let's let me be direct
on this one
during the dot-com bubble in the 90s
a lot of people started companies
and a lot of them tried pretty much
every idea you can imagine
right every idea that you see today has
some analog from the 90s
so dig in look into it like see if
people have tried this before right
same deal in the 2000s
people pretty much tried every idea
and again
maybe in the example of something like
instacart people had tried instacart
before it didn't work but the founders
of instacart knew that and they
intentionally designed it to be better
you understand what i'm saying like like
they stood on the shoulders of those
that came before them
smart
versus if you're the founder of
instacart and you didn't realize that
webvan existed
how is that hope like you're not helping
yourself to not know about it same in
the 2010s think about how many startups
we funded their tricep before and so
from our perspective
we see patterns and the ideas people
start constantly
and
we get it you know you're better smarter
faster you have a better programming
language or you know whatever it is
you're better you know we better ui
dalton i got better ui
you know oh mobile i remember in our in
our era when we were young founders it
was like oh we're an app we're an iphone
app iphone changes everything which is
built true
but doesn't mean we should have
discounted history
you know dalton as you were saying this
something occurred to me
the platforms change faster than the
human problems
so like you and i have lived through one
web 100 web 2o
mobile and whatever the hell yeah
platform yeah we've seen many of these
but it turns out that like i want to go
grocery shopping but i don't want to go
to the grocery store
that's been a problem the whole time
like or i want to get good food
delivered to me in where i am so i don't
have to go get it same human problem the
whole i want to get a job
same problem
and i think that's maybe the logical
reason why you should do the research
because it's almost guaranteed you're
not solving a new problem you're just
using a slightly new technique
or a new technology or something new to
try to attack an old problem let's study
how everyone else tried to attack the
old problem
and it's weird because you know
sometimes rarely but sometimes you're
doing something on the internet that
hasn't been put on the internet for um
that hasn't been done internet before
you know with justin tv live video
hadn't really been done on the internet
before
what was interesting was
almost inadvertently we got to learn
about the old way because we started
getting a lot of press coverage
and we started getting a lot of these um
old-fashioned video guys doing live
video news coverage of us
and we would see them with their like
van would pull up and it's like we beam
this from the camera to the van to the
microwave thing on that hill over there
it's gotta all line up and we're like oh
[__] like
and that was like state of the art and
so
to me it's like wow watching that we
were like well you know our thing isn't
as good as theirs but it's way easier
than having a van and a microwave dish
up on a hill so
nellie plays devil's advocate a little
bit
dalton
i have an expert advisor
i have an angel investor i have a seed
investor i've got a series a investor
they're the experienced ones and they
believe
they're working with me like isn't that
validation enough
don't they didn't they do this research
kind of i mean let's go to this two ways
one
it's best to do your own work on this
um because ultimately you're responsible
for your company and it working or not
and this is what i tell people in the
batch you know i'm like well just make
sure
you know you have to live you have to
live your life so if your star doesn't
work it's not really my problem you know
like like i'll i'll be okay
and so feel like you've done all of the
diligence and research and you know the
risks of what you're doing but you know
to the extent i have relevant advice it
could be helpful i think the other thing
is sometimes experts can be too biased
positively or negatively based on a
small data set so if you're working on a
startup idea that someone
had either personally worked on before
or lost lots of money invested in before
they're going to have opinions
in my case
you know media and entertainment
startups are really hard so i you know i
know a lot about them
i can advise people on them but i'm not
usually the most optimistic
on that startup idea
um
and then and so when you're talking to
experts
just make sure you get a wide variety of
them i think would be my
my
reaction to your pushback and synthesize
them just in the same way i said earlier
it's good to listen to lots of different
kinds of music to synthesize together i
would just be
synthesizing a lot of different opinions
or a lot of different pieces of history
as you're forming an opinion you know in
the in the brex example they went and
spoke to every person that ever tried to
start a challenger bank before and guess
what they all told them they told them
two things one useful information
that they wrote down in their notes the
founders of did and two they told him
don't do this are you crazy
so they had the breakfast ignored that
part but this is similar when you speak
to experts
you just need to know what bits and
pieces to draw from what they have to
say than to blindly accept what they say
as facts and that includes us totally
right you know i think you bought up
something so counterintuitive about
investors like
i get so many emails from people saying
like i'm doing social this or live video
that
can you help me
and like i'm one of those people who's
like wow i've i took a lot of hits
during my social media live video days
like
i
i think sometimes counterintuitively
investors who know slightly less about
your space can be a little bit more
grasses greener
like optimistic than folks who
know more about your space and i think
that's not something that i realized i
don't think something that's obvious to
founders i think that like
people assume expertise equals optimism
yeah right haven't we observed the
opposite of that
yeah i mean yeah there's something nice
about not knowing much about something
it's much easier to see it is a simple
question or a simple problem
like imagine asking
the founders of doordash about food
delivery and what they would have to say
about it versus
me versus
yeah exactly
yes